c'est le deuxième port en importance au
canada après vancouver le deuxième aussi
dans le nord-est américain après new
york
chaque année 2000 navire visite le port
de montréal et 40 millions de tonnes de
marchandises y transitent
on peut dire d'emblée que c'est le port
le plus important pour l'économie
québécoise ou notamment pour les aspects
de produits manufacturés donc tous qui
transigent par les contenants qui est
parce qu il ya marché d'un conflit
actuel 1 million 700 mille conteneurs
sont manutentionné chaque année au port
la valeur quotidienne de la marchandise
transportée ensuite en camion ou en
train et évalués à 275 millions de
dollars
c'est la part principale pour toute la
région de chute de l'ontario donc est
marrant c'est également aussi il faut
pas l'oublier importe première
importance pour le midwest américain
donc il ya des liaisons ferroviaires
directement des quais du port de
montréal vers détroit et chicago
le port est d'une importance capitale
pour l'économie montréalaise entre deux
et trois mille personnes y travaillent
dont les 1125 débardeur en grève depuis
ce matin ajoutez à cela
6300 entreprises qui sont rattachés pour
toutes les opérations de logistique et
de transport
prenez n'importe quelle industrie
majeure au canada et au québec
et vous avez un composante maritime qui
est essentiel donc c'est vraiment toute
l'ossature de notre organisation sociale
économique sur le transport
dans ce contexte une grève prolongée
pourrait faire très mal
une récente étude économique a conclu
que conflit de dix jours engendrerait
des pertes quotidiennes de 10 à 25
millions de dollars pour l'économie
canadienne
au-delà des chiffres parce qu'un des
mains des indicateurs qui moi me semble
révélateur c'est la vitesse avec
laquelle nos politiciens interviennent
et évoque la possibilité d'une loi
spéciale
selon un sondage de la fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
la pression exercée l'été dernier par
les débardeurs du
or qui ont débrayé 19 x a été ressenti
par quatre pme sur dix au québec
personne n'a intérêt à ce que le conflit
actuel perdu ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal